cómo
vamos
buenos días que tal como mencionaron mi
nombre
estando maría arroyo y yo soy 'general
manager' el número específicamente para
el área central
y me da mucho gusto seguir luego de ma
sofía ya que dado que yo trabajo en über
vamos a hablar de cosas muy parecidas de
hecho tenemos las mismas preocupaciones
de lo que les voy a hablar hoy día es
del futuro de la movilidad
entonces que nos preocupa nos preocupa
cómo nos movemos cómo podemos usar la
tecnología para mejorar el transporte en
las ciudades
un dato que ya deben haber visto es que
hay de más de 1200 millones de vehículos
en el mundo esto es la población de
china y europa combinada
y qué significa esto con estos números
de fácil demonizar a los autos es fácil
decir preocuparse por el espacio que
ocupa sin embargo el problema no
necesariamente es que tantos vehículos
hay sino como los usamos me imagino que
todos vienen en carro en algún método de
transporte cuando se detengan en un
semáforo en rojo volteen y miren a los
vehículos a su alrededor cuántos
vehículos tienen sólo una persona
entonces el problema como los utilizamos
como desperdiciamos esta capacidad
instalada de un vehículo que puede que
puede transportar por lo menos hasta 5
personas normalmente estos 20 estos
vehículos tienen solo al conductor
entonces como ya se mencionaron pasamos
mucho tiempo detrás el volante el
mejicano que conduce por lo general está
alrededor de dos horas al día esto
obviamente produce mucho
congestionamiento en la ciudad además de
eso el 22 por ciento de las emisiones de
carbono son causadas por medios de
transporte entonces cuando los autos
están en movimiento generan muchas
externalidades negativas para la ciudad
sin embargo
esto solamente es el inicio de los del
problema ya lo mencionaron pero estos
vehículos en movimiento son solamente el
5 por ciento del tiempo de utilización
de un vehículo el 95 por ciento del
tiempo estos vehículos están
estacionados
para que tengan una idea de lo grande
que es este problema eeuu tiene
alrededor de 8 lugares de
estacionamiento por vehículo esto
equivale a más o menos 12 veces el
tamaño de la ciudad de nueva york
entonces todo este espacio que podría
haber sido utilizado en parques en vías
de bicicletas en espacios deportivos es
utilizado para estacionar estos inmensos
vehículos bloques de acero es claramente
no estamos permitiendo que nuestras
ciudades se conviertan en ciudades
verdes las estamos usando para poner
estos vehículos y otra cosa que también
nos impacta es que las ciudades se están
diseñando en función a esto por ejemplo
muchas ciudades tienen reglamentos que
obligan a los constructores de vivienda
o de oficinas a tener un mínimo de
vehículos entonces si quieres tener x
número de departamentos el número mínimo
de estacionamientos es y entonces los
mismos constructores están diseñando y
están levantando ciudades con estas
restricciones
pensemos en un ejemplo que nosotros
pensamos que es una de las ciudades con
menor porcentaje de vehículos por
persona nueva york entonces si ven en
este mapa la isla de ella es la de
manhattan el pedazo saliente de la
esquina y para los que han ido manhattan
saben que mucha gente no tiene un
vehículo la mayoría gente se movilice
está a 13 metros que es un sistema de
transporte urbano bastante eficiente sin
embargo obviamente en manhattan trabajan
muchísimas personas a pesar de tener uno
de los transportes de uno de los
sistemas de transporte público más
avanzados del mundo
igual hay 2.7 millones de vehículos
entrando a manhattan todos los días
qué significa esto que obviamente hay
congestionamiento vehícular a la hora de
entrada a la hora de salida a pesar de
tener un sistema de transporte público
bastante avanzado
ahora cuando los fundadores de uber
empezaron a diseñar la idea obviamente
no le diseñaron pensando cómo hacemos
para mejorar el futuro y la movilidad de
las ciudades lo que querían era una
solución práctica a un problema que creo
que todos hemos vivido salir a la calle
querer movilizarse a un sitio y no tener
una opción de transporte público porque
tal vez es un poco tarde puede ser no sé
23 de la mañana el metro ya cerró tal
vez hace frío no estar parado en el frío
10 minutos entonces pensaron en cómo
solucionar esto
se creó la que creó la solución de
empresas de red de transporte y luego
después de un tiempo ésta empezó a
escalar en una necesidad que teníamos
todos en común empieza a escalar empieza
a ir a más países a más ciudades y una
vez que se logra la escala es que se ven
las externalidades positivas de una
modalidad de transporte como la que
tiene uber entonces a través de la
congruencia de la tecnología con la
infraestructura actual vehículos calles
etcétera se desarrolla una solución que
tiene un muy buen impacto en las
ciudades
hablemos vestida de méxico lo que esté
light nos muestra es lo siguiente cuando
no hay uno cuando se empieza a operar
una ciudad lo que sucede al principio es
que los primeros viajes son en la zona
centro en la zona centro no hay más
concentración de personas más
concentración de viviendas más
concentración de oficinas a medida que
el servicio va escalando se va la
periferia qué es lo que sucede en la
periferia lo que suele suceder es que
hay una población de menor ingreso y que
los sistemas de transporte no llegan
hasta en los suburbios hasta la
periferia una ciudad que quiere decir es
que piensen en cualquier ciudad
básicamente vivir en las afueras quiere
decir a veces tener un menor acceso a
transporte público como hicieron esas
personas a estos puntos
consiste con empresas de redes de
transporte lo que sucede es que se cubre
la ciudad entera ciudad de mexico tiene
1.500 kilómetros cuadrados sin embargo
lo que se ha logrado el día de hoy es
cubrir a la ciudad entera con un tiempo
promedio de espera de cinco minutos esto
quiere decir que toda la población
cuando lo necesite puede acceder a un
sistema de transporte seguro confiable y
rápido
ahora obviamente esto no sólo suceden
cios de méxico
en el caso de parís parís sucede lo
mismo en las zonas marginadas están en
las afueras en la ciudad se pasa
exactamente lo mismo empezamos en el
centro y luego la demanda se va
expandiendo cubriendo todas estas zonas
dándole más acceso a quienes más lo
necesitan a nuevas a nuevas modalidades
de transporte y la idea no es que todo
el mundo se moviliza en vehículo sino
que se complementen los servicios
otro fenómeno que me imagino ustedes
deben haber experimentado
cuando yo estaba en la universidad ya
más de 10 años salíamos viernes sábados
en la noche a tomar unas cervezas y lo
que sucedía es que en el retorno no
había un método confiable para regresar
esto derivaba en que algunas personas
tomaban de la decisión de manejar bajo
la influencia del alcohol
precisamente porque es un horario tal
vez en donde el transporte público no
está disponible lo que hemos visto otra
vez en nuestra data este viernes en la
noche y estábamos en la noche es un
horario en donde la gente si bien no
pueden usar el servicio todos los días
decide dejar su auto en casa y hacer y
tomar un servicio mediante el cual vamos
a sentir seguros y no van a manejar bajo
la influencia del alcohol
entonces como pueden ver en esta gráfica
en muchas ciudades las solicitudes en
horarios como viernes en la noche estado
en la noche aumentan cual es la
externalidad positiva para una ciudad
en nueva york desde el lanzamiento del
servicio se dice que los accidentes por
consumo de bebidas alcohólicas bajaron
en alrededor de un 25% esto es un
impacto muy positivo para la ciudad
hacer que se disminuyan los accidentes
yo no sé a dónde apuntar
y cómo
entonces también lo que les decía la
idea no es reemplazar el transporte
público no es que se dejen de usar
bicicletas u scooters la idea es
desarrollar servicios para darle mejores
posibilidades de movilidad de una ciudad
si ven por ejemplo aquí en nueva york
que es lo que habíamos dicho manhattan
es el pedazo más brillante si bien hay
una gran concentración estos viajes se
dirigen a las afueras y además a medida
que crece el servicio pueden ver como
puntos más lejanos empiezan viajes y se
dirigen hacia el centro de la ciudad
entonces se atiende una población que
antes no tenía este acceso
y en cuanto a complementariedad con el
servicio público lo que podemos ver es
el gasto de londres londres tiene un
sistema de transporte público bastante
avanzado a través de metros y vemos que
el 30 por ciento de los viajes empiezan
a 200 metros de una estación de metro
entonces estamos hablando de transporte
de primera y última milla es decir yo me
voy a mover en metro lo que voy a hacer
es voy a tomar un lugar para llegar al
metro me voy a transportar en metro y
eso me va a llevar de puerta a puerta
entonces imagínense una ciudad en donde
puedo tener en una aplicación comprar mi
servicio de puerta a puerta quiero que
un lugar me lleva hasta el metro quiero
que a través de mi celular yo pueda
accesar al metro bajarme el metro y tal
vez subirme una bicicleta porque es una
zona de alto tránsito o este tráfico y
llegar a mi centro de trabajo
a esto estamos apuntando
a un futuro donde la movilidad es
multimodal en donde lo puedes hacer todo
en una aplicación y gracias a la
tecnología en donde cada persona puede
elegir yo quiero optimizar por tiempo
tal vez es más rápido irme en un auto
quiero optimizar por recurso económico
entonces tal vez lo más eficiente es
combinar bicicleta con metro y con un
vehículo a ese ahí es ahí a donde
queremos ir a dónde queremos llegar
otra cosa que también nos ayuda mucho es
ser una empresa de tecnología es la
calidad y cantidad de data que podemos
generar al igual que lo que vieron con
la sociedad de weiss nosotros también
tenemos muchísima data de cómo se mueve
la gente hacia dónde va cuáles son las
zonas de tránsito cuáles son las zonas
de tráfico y la idea aquí es trabajar de
la mano de los reguladores para que
ellos también puedan diseñar en función
a nuestra data como hacemos para que
hayan más líneas de transporte público
relevante cómo hacemos para que el
precio sea el correcto para las
diferentes población que tienen en la
ciudad y cómo generamos acceso para
aquellas personas que el día de hoy nos
están poniendo a mover de manera
eficiente
y por último otra de las externalidades
positivas en las que le quería hablar es
del producto que se llama pool pool no
es una idea nueva pool no es algo que
esté lanzó en los últimos años se empezó
a hablar de modalidades como puzzles la
segunda guerra mundial en los setentas
con la crisis del petróleo también los
reguladores decían no sería increíble
subir a más de una o dos personas en el
auto sin embargo no teníamos la
tecnología para hacerlo para hacerlo
realidad dado que ahora tenemos la data
y la tecnología lo que ven los
ingenieros es personas moviéndose desde
un destino parecido hasta desde un
origen parecido hasta un destino
parecido entonces con esto qué es lo que
podemos generar que dos personas que
nunca se hablaron en la vida y que no
saben quiénes son pueden subirse en el
mismo vehículo y puedan ser
transportadas de manera eficiente se
hace esto obviamente reduce el número de
vehículos en la ciudad todavía
hay muchas complejidades a lograr esto
de una forma eficiente en una ciudad tan
grande como ciudad de mexico
como hacemos que todos los extremos se
conecte como hacemos que la congestión
no sea un tema que por recoger al
segundo pasajero se incremente el tiempo
de espera en 15 minutos todavía hay
muchos problemas que resolver pero esto
definitivamente te reduce el número de
vehículos en la ciudad y te genera más
espacio para más espacios públicos menos
estacionamientos etcétera entonces sé
que también ya hablaron de esto
en eeuu los usuarios de über de menos de
30 años y al 10% dicen que no tendrán ni
tendrían un auto propio esto es en
personas en menos de 30 me imagino que a
quienes tienen hijos hermanos menores y
yo para ellos tener un vehículo va a ser
completamente innecesario al día de hoy
ya muchos de nosotros tal vez no
tengamos un vehículo y no lo veamos como
algo necesario entonces en el futuro
podremos combinar y de nuevo no solo
vehículos sino diferentes modalidades de
transporte para no tener que poseer este
activo
y según un estudio de morgan stanley
para el 2030 el 25 por ciento de los
viajes serán en modalidades compartidas
pero no 25% de las millas recorridas al
día de hoy con todo lo que nos movemos
en las diferentes haciendo uso de de
viajes compartidos solamente representa
el 4% con una tendencia de crecimiento
enorme para el 2030 ya vemos que esto es
una realidad y el 25 por ciento de los
de las millas van a ser en viajes
compartidos y obviamente algo que de lo
que ya hablaron también es de los coches
autónomos no solamente coches autónomos
sino coches autónomos compartidos los
coches de autónomos compartidos tienen
el potencial de reducir hasta el 90 por
ciento el número de autos en las calles
entonces imagínense el espacio que
ganaríamos y no solamente tenemos que
hablar de de coches autónomas en unos
años si ya se van a empezar a pilotear
los coches aéreos con perdón los
vehículos aéreos compartidos
esto se ha anunciado públicamente y se
está hablando de podernos transportar
desde el centro de prime imaginemos la
avenida reforma hasta el aeropuerto un
viernes de quincena en 15 minutos
entonces de nuevo vemos en un futuro en
donde existen diferentes modalidades y
modalidades más eficientes
nosotros nos imaginamos que en el futuro
las ciudades van a poder ser más verdes
van a poder ser más inclusivas vamos a
hacer mejor uso de los recursos vamos a
disminuir el espacio estacionamientos
vamos a ver menos congestión vamos a ver
menos contaminación queremos pasar de
junglas de concreto a espacios verdes
amigables para todos los ciudadanos
y finalmente esto es lo que nosotros en
visión amos como el futuro de la
movilidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]